We're on problem 27.
They tell us if i is equal to
the square root of minus 1,
then what is 4 times i-- that's
an i-- times 6 times i?
Well, multiplication
is associative.
You can switch the
order around.
So this is the same thing as 4
times 6 times i times i, or
the same thing as 24 times
i squared, right?
If we square both sides of this,
you get i squared is
equal to negative 1.
So this is 24 times
negative 1.
So this is minus 24,
which is choice C.
Next problem, 28.
They want to know what
an equivalent
form of 3 plus i is.
A lot of times, people don't
like either when you have a
square root in the denominator
or they don't like it when you
have an a complex number
in the denominator.
A complex number is just
something that has part real
and part imaginary.
So the way you can do it with
this case is you multiply
times the conjugate
of this number.
I know that sounds like a fancy
word, but all it means
is you take the opposite
of the imaginary part.
So what's the conjugate?
Remember, the only way you
cannot change a fraction is if
you multiply the numerator and
the denominator by the same
thing, because then you're
multiplying by 1.
So what's the conjugate
of this?
The conjugate of 3 plus
i is 3 minus i.
You have to do 3 minus
i over 3 minus i.
I'm doing that because when you
multiply a complex number
by its conjugate, you end up
actually with a real number.
Then you're going to end up with
a complex number up here.
A conjugate, all it means is
you keep the real part the
same, and you change the sign
on the imaginary part.
That's all that word means.
All right, now let's figure
out what this is equal to.
2 times 3, just same
distributive
properties as always.
Let me do it in green.
2 times 3 is 6.
2 times minus i is minus
2i, all of that over
3 times 3 is 9.
3 times minus i is minus 3i.
i times 3 is plus 3i.
Then i times minus i, you can
view that as minus i squared.
Let's think about what
this is equal to.
Well, this plus 3i and the
minus 3i cancel out.
What's i squared?
Well, this is equal
to negative 1.
So you end up with a minus
of a negative 1.
Minus a negative
1 is a plus 1.
So you're left with 6 minus
2i over 9 plus 1 over 10.
Actually, we can reduce
this some.
We can divide the top
and the bottom by 2.
So that becomes 3
minus i over 5.
We just divided both the
numerator and the
denominator by 2.
That is choice B.
Problem 29, these go
fast. No systems of
equations and all that.
What is the product of the
complex numbers 3 plus
i and 3 minus i?
They just asked us that.
That was in the last problem.
When we multiplied 3 plus
i times 3 minus
i, what did we get?
We got 10.
We did this whole thing.
3 times 3 is 9.
We did the whole thing.
They're just repeating
the same question.
That equals 10.
That's choice B.
Rewind the video and see
what I did here.
3 times 3 is 9 times minus 3i
plus 3i minus i squared.
These terms cancel out and you
get a minus i squared, which
is minus negative 1.
So you have 9 plus 1,
so that equals 10.
So that is choice B.
That's crazy.
They just gave us the same
problem twice in a row.
All right.
They're giving us more and more
imaginary problems. But
these are fun, especially if
they're going to repeat the
same question.
Problem 30, if i is equal to
the square root of negative
1-- well, I'll just keep writing
it because they keep
writing it.
It's good as a reminder. i is
equal to the square root of
negative 1 and a and b are
non-zero real numbers.
What is 1 over a plus bi?
Well, once again, if they kind
of want us to rewrite this,
they probably just want us to
get rid of the i's in the
denominator.
So we multiply times
the conjugate of
this complex number.
So we multiply times a plus
bi, the conjugate over the
conjugate, a plus bi.
The conjugate isn't
this whole thing.
The conjugate is
just a plus bi.
Oh sorry, we should be
multiplying times a minus bi.
a minus bi over a minus bi.
The conjugate of a plus bi,
just so you get the
terminology right, is
just the a minus bi.
But I'm doing a minus
bi over a minus bi.
So I'm not changing this
fraction because this
obviously is 1.
x over x is the same
thing as 1.
So let's see what this
is equal to.
Well, the numerator just becomes
a minus bi times 1,
which is a minus bi.
Then you have a times a,
which is a squared.
a times minus bi, so
it's minus abi.
Then you have bi times
a, which is plus abi.
I'll write it down here.
They cancel out.
Then you have bi
times minus bi.
So that's minus b squared
i squared.
These cancel out.
So you're left with a minus
bi over a squared
minus b squared i squared.
We know what i squared is.
i squared is equal
to negative 1.
You square both sides of that
and you get i squared is equal
to negative 1.
So if we multiply, this
becomes a negative 1.
But then this negative and this
negative, they cancel out.
You get a plus.
So then we get a minus bi over
a squared plus b squared.
That is choice B.
Next problem.
All right, what are the
solutions to the equation x
squared plus 2x plus 2?
All right, now, if you see an
equation like this and you're
like, OK, let's see,
can I factor it?
Oh, that is equal to 0.
You say, OK, what number when
I multiple them equal 2 and
when I add them equal 2?
Well, that's a hard one.
Whenever you get stuck, the
easiest thing to do is just
use the quadratic equation,
just as a reminder.
If the equation is Ax squared
plus Bx plus C-- maybe I
should have done them all in in
capital letters-- is equal
to 0, the solution to this and
the proof of this we've done
in the Khan Academy, it comes
from completing the square,
but it's useful to memorize,
is negative B.
So the solutions are x are equal
to negative B plus or
minus the square root of B
squared minus 4AC, all
of that over 2A.
So in this case, what is A?
A is the coefficient
on x squared.
So A is equal to 1.
What is B?
B is the coefficient on x.
So B is equal to 2.
What is C?
C is just a constant term.
So C is equal to 2.
We could just solve like that,
just substitute these values.
So you get x is equal to minus
B, which is minus 2, plus or
minus the square root of
B squared, so that's 4,
minus 4 minus A.
So 4 minus 4 times A, 4 times
1, times 2, all of that--
that's an ugly looking radical--
all of that over 2A,
2 times 1 is 2.
So that equals, let's see, we
get minus 2 plus or minus the
square root of 4 minus--
this is 8, right?
4 times 1 times 2.
4 minus 8, which is minus 4, all
of that over 2, which is
equal to minus 2
plus or minus.
So the square root of minus 4,
we could rewrite that as the
square root of 4
times minus 1.
So that equals 2 plus or minus
the square root of 4 times the
square root of minus 1, all of
that over 2, which is equal to
minus 2 plus or minus-- the
square root of 4 is 2 and the
plus or minus is dealing with
positive or negative 2-- times
the square root of negative 1.
Well, we learned that's
i multiple times.
The square root of negative 1
is i, all of that over 2.
We can simplify this
a little bit.
I'll do it in a different color,
just because I've run
out of space at the
bottom here.
So this is equal to divide
everything by 2, you get
negative 1 plus or minus i.
Let's see what the
choices are.
That's choice C, because
negative 1 plus or minus i
could also be written as
negative 1 plus i as one value
for x, and then the other one
could be negative 1 minus i.
They separate it out.
They don't write plus or minus
in the actual problem.
I'm out of time.
I'll see you in the next video.
you in the next video